die zeit vom 7 das nehmen sie ja
ziemlich locker mit coolness und
coolness mit ehre und dazu jetzt eine
ziemlich spannende diskussionen im
fragen lotto und sie erklären auch warum
sie kein stück real sind das und noch
viel mehr jetzt in verantwortung
wir sind gemeinde und harmlose fragen
die die harmlosen sind grünen die
anderen sind rot ihr könnt selber
entscheiden wie viel ob und überhaupt
ihr zieht jeder kantine grünen fragen
eingefallen oder so gut wie keiner ließ
vor euch gegenseitig [ __ ] und hat
teilweise makabere bis böse zeilen gegen
eure familienmitglieder auf dem album
seid ihr noch leitet seit ihr nicht
total ehren los weil das ding ja eben
unsere mütter haben einfach humor ist
der punkt eins unsere mütter haben
wie heißt das wo ich kenne das nicht
courage ist das neu darüber zu stehen
weil sie sie natürlich wissen was besser
was wahr ist und was einfach übernehmen
uns ja zu hause wir sind ja keine miss
geboten ich will reden rät mir alter und
vom ehren los ich habe ja keine ehre
alter ich brauch keine ehre verteidigt
aber das ist doch wahnsinnig wichtig
sich ständig wird über ihre geredet und
das ist auch wichtig aber doch nur bei
offenem scheiß weinrebe weil die ähren
da hängen bleiben müssen bis der neue
piste aber ich habe keine ehre alter
ich brauch keine ehre verteidigen weil
ich einfach weiß wie ich bin okay ich
habe einen satz gehört das fand ich echt
killer wegen dieser ehrenscheibe
es gibt leute die ehre haben und es gibt
welche die behauptung die von ehre reden
ich finde ich finde das richtig zu
treffen weil ich also bei so leuten so
die sofort voll gemein werden sich
sofort immer schlagen mussten dann ich
weiß nicht die haben die die in meiner
tasche dabei oder weil ich finde dass
voll behindert
warum also ich bin mal ich hab mir
überlege ich habe überlegt und was
eigentlich ehre ist also man möchte ja
respektvoll behandelt werden das ist ja
schon klar möchte nicht
ich war eigentlich dass ganz oft
gekränkte eitelkeiten ich bin aber ich
möchte nicht wie luft behandelt werden
und jetzt wenden oder mehr raus das ist
meistens so also das sind die leute die
keine bis wenig freunde bzw intelligenz
besitzen und die müssen sich über solche
sachen profilieren einfach die müssen
dann wenn einer mal zu den hohen sagt
direkt boxen und sagen emotionen sorgt
es keiner keiner sagte zu mir ich hätte
ihn gekriegt aber das ist total dumm das
ist einfach ein ständiges krankes denken
also wenn jeder so denken würde werden
schon sieben atombombe gefallen finde
ich geil wie schafft er es so real zu
bleiben
die frage jetzt mal ehrlich alter wer
auch immer die gestellt hatte das kannst
du nicht ernst mein alter wir sind doch
kein stück rielmann aber es ist ohne
scheiß wie wir es schaffen so wie wir es
schaffen soviel zu bleiben das ist ganz
leicht
wir machen einfach wenn wir den text
geschrieben haben gehen wir raus und
machen sofort alles was wir da drin
geschrieben und trashig und albern
eigentlich geschichten vom gescheiterten
existenzen brauch guck ich prosieben
oder rtl dann brauche ich keine pop
album hören wir machen die bandbreite
größer weil wir unterstellen wollen
keine dokumente
ihr seid doch nur eine schlechte kopie
warum die drei rapper sind kiz sind drei
rapper und ein dj fick dich mutter
fisher und weil wir kein gangster rap
machen
ich töte dich störst du dir nach hause
ich weiß wo du wohl das macht keule aber
ich finde wir sind ehrlich keine kopie
von kiz und ich wette ich vor wette
alter mann beide ja und mein himmel
darauf dass die kiz jungs auch niemals
sagen würden dass wir eine kopie von den
sind wahrscheinlich nicht aber das wäre
warum denkt ihr denn alle
er schwänzte bis drei zählen können
respekt
sechs eure texte strotzen ja nicht
gerade von intellekt sind eure hier ein
hohlraum versiegelt was ist das ganz
ehrlich gibt nur etwas was man aber hier
sind abgeblendet von diesem auf [ __ ]
und wir machen doch voll rhetorische
musik mit vollen kassen
es gibt solche leute die unsere musik
feiern und verstehen die sie toll finden
es gibt solche die es nicht finden und
das ist mir egal ich hab noch was schön
ist was machst du heute was macht euch
unsere und verwechselbar foto von mir
cook wer noch so aussieht und find den
wecken der sieht anders aus ich bin
unverwechselbar pass auf nächste frage
257 das hr nsn wie wollt ihr mit so
einem verwirrenden namen und so einem
unaussprechlichen albumtitel überhaupt
erfolgreich werden also diese wie gesagt
das hatten wir ja hr ns verein ist
eigentlich recht leicht auszusprechen
dass alles großbuchstaben sind und
großbuchstaben hintereinander
geschrieben in der deutschen sprache
meistens einzeln ausgesprochen werden
das heißt nicht hören sind wir leben ja
nicht in der eu- und gucken auch kein
mit und fliegen mit in den urlaub
deswegen sexualität das waren 257 das
und verlinkt jetzt das frage lotto mit
commander krieger der unter anderem über
seine arschloch partei berichtet was es
mit ihr auf sich hat oder auch lustig
dass mit pukki dem entwickler von edna
bricht aus jan müller michaelis der von
seinem peter pan syndrom erzählt dass
unbedingt wichtig ist um gute spiele zu
programmieren und darüber dass er ein
ego-shooter loop ist das und viel mehr
in diesen beiden fragen lottos auf
clixoom bis dann bleibt dran